[Music]
Billy Pilgrim can't sleep because he
knows aliens will arrive to abduct him
in one hour
he knows the aliens are coming because
he has become unstuck in time causing
him to experience events out of
chronological order over the course of
Kurt Vonnegut's slaughterhouse-five he
hops back and forth between a childhood
trip to the Grand Canyon his life as a
middle-aged optometrist his captivity in
an intergalactic Zoo the humiliations he
endured as a war prisoner and more the
title of slaughterhouse-five and much of
its source material came from Vonnegut's
own experiences in world war ii as a
prisoner of war
he lived in a former slaughterhouse in
Dresden where he took refuge in an
underground meat locker while Allied
forces bombed the city when he and the
other prisoners finally emerged they
found Dresden utterly demolished after
the war
Vonnegut tried to make sense of human
behavior by studying an unusual aspect
of anthropology the shapes of stories
which he insisted were just as
interesting as the shapes of pots or
spear heads to find the shape he graphed
the main characters fortune from the
beginning to the end of a story the zany
curves he generated revealed common
types of fairy tales and myths that echo
through many cultures but this shape can
be the most interesting of all in a
story like this it's impossible to
distinguish the characters good fortune
from the bad Vonnegut thought this kind
of story was the truest to real life in
which we are all the victims of a series
of accidents unable to predict how
events will impact us long-term he found
the tidy satisfying arcs of many stories
at odds with this reality and he set out
to explore the ambiguity between good
and bad fortune in his own work when
Vonnegut ditched clear-cut fortunes he
also abandoned straightforward
chronology instead of proceeding tidally
from beginning to end in his stories all
moments passed
and future always have existed always
will exist tralfamadorians the aliens
who crop up in many of his books see all
moments at once they can see where each
star has been and where it is going so
that the heavens are filled with
rarefied luminous spaghetti but although
they can see all of time they don't try
to change the course of events while the
tralfamadorians may be at peace with
their lack of agency Vonnegut's human
characters are still getting used to it
in the sirens of Titan when they seek
the meaning of life in the vastness of
the universe they find nothing but empty
heroics low comedy and pointless death
then from their vantage point within a
chrono sink plastic infundibulum a man
and his dog see devastating futures for
their earthly counterparts but can't
change the course of events though there
aren't easy answers available
they eventually conclude that the
purpose of life is to love whoever is
around to be loved in cat's cradle
Vonnegut's characters turn to a
different source of meaning volcanism a
religion based on harmless lies that all
its adherents recognize as lies though
they're aware of Bokan isms lies they
live their lives by these tenets anyway
and in so doing develop some genuine
hope they join together in groups called
Karaca z' which consist of people we
find by accident but stick with by
choice
cosmically linked around a shared
purpose these are not to be confused
with grandfa lunes groups of people who
appoint significance to actually
meaningless associations like where you
grew up political parties and even
entire nations though he held a bleak
view of the human condition
Vonnegut believed strongly that we are
all here to help each other get through
this thing whatever it is we might get
pooped and demoralized but Vonnegut
interspersed his grim assessments with
more than a few morsels of hope his
fictional alter-ego
Kilgore trout supplied this parable
- yeast sat discussing the possible
purposes of life as they ate sugar and
suffocated in their own expert because
of their limited intelligence they never
came close to guessing that they were
making champagne in spite of his
insistence that were all here to fart
around in spite of his deep concerns
about the course of human existence
Vonnegut also advanced the possibility
however slim that we might end up making
something good and if that isn't nice
what is if we've managed to pique your
interest you can download an audio
version of slaughterhouse-five
for free at audible.com slash ted-ed and
thanks every free trial started through
this link help support Ted's nonprofit
mission
[Music]